the lecture and daredevil just found the
big hole in the ground then you should
check lecture and daredevil just kind of
like hole in the ground as we don't just
and you should check lecture in
daredevil just eat to know just like
holding losses and breakdowns for some
of your favorite shows where you can
call in and talk with us directly and
unlike the official post shows we don't
have to suck up to any network overlords
featuring fan favorites like knocking
dead where we break down all the zombie
action watching throws where we follow
all the intrigue in Westeros debugging
mr. robot where we debug mr. robot and
coming this fall we get our superhero
crush on with rewinding flash shooting
arrow and seeing Supergirl
sorry Gotham Plus don't forget the small
screen big drama version of movie fights
TV fights with Roxie stryer just that
alone is worth it but why stop there
we've doubled the amount of show since
our launch and we're adding new shows
every month including exclusive stuff
with Doug Benson and continuing your
favorites with awesome people like Kevin
Smith screen junkies Plus now even +
e'er we really got to work on our tag
lines oh and one more thing for any TV
junkies who sign up now using promo code
SJ central 60 you'll get 50% off our
annual membership seriously though
is Gotham still on I am in Washington a
while you're watching screen junkies
central today's episode is brought to
you by t-mobile
the uncarrier
oh uh welcome to scream junkie central
I'm Hal Rudnick and with me you know him
you love them Andre Meadows aka the
black nerd what's up everybody I like
sitting it this feels like a geek
sporting event like coming to you live
from San Diego
we have cosplay war Andre there are some
intense nerds out there I have seen a
Batman and a Joker eating hamburgers I
saw an overweight Deadpool fall to the
ground from heat exhaustion it's
pandemonium um Andre thank you for being
here my man thanks for having me thank
you guys for having me I really
appreciate this this is awesome yeah um
so we are here for a pretty cool panel
go go it's the Power Rangers and I
wouldn't want to host this or co-host
this with anyone but Andre Meadows
because you the child is alive inside of
you Andre
context uh so no no I'm really excited
it's it cuz I who grew up on Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers who watched it
whoo back in the 90s I remember watching
it it's morphin time and they're all
into getting absorbs you know then Tommy
shows up Green Ranger you know I just
all that is so good and I went to see my
own from our original movie back in the
90s I saw Turbo Power Rangers movie in
the theater Wow any guide on DVD but
I've always been want another one and
now I'm so excited about this one I'm
super stoked I really am
absolutely yeah I can tell I mean you're
giddy as a schoolgirl
I am super giddy and um and I'm also
glad to have you here because I'm a
little bit of a neophyte when it comes
to the Power Ranger yeah yeah yeah so
let me ask you a question oh boy what's
the difference between the Power Rangers
in Voltron uh well the Power Rangers are
live-action to a certain extent whereas
Voltron to animate it and it's the thing
about Power Rangers is as they say on
the show they're teenagers with attitude
there's he's cool and he's cool guys but
it's like it's neat because there's a
person for everybody like you got Jason
who's like really cool collective a
leader yeah you got Billy who's a smart
the nerd for the nerds in the house you
got Kimberly a Trini
Zak my boy Zak with the freaking to
hip-hop Kido nice he he looks the same
like you've ever seen him person Walter
Jones that dude black Ranger don't crack
it's almost look he looks really good
but it was just so awesome because they
were these different personalities that
came together and they were just always
fun together I always said it was like
Saved by the Bell
except they also fought monsters and put
ice and things like that and then when
they all you know more if they get into
their suits red blue pink yellow black
eventually green eventually white and
then then they call them there's orange
you know you got the Zords are all based
on dinosaurs right at the Tyrannosaurus
you got the saber-toothed tiger you got
Mastodon pterodactyl Triceratops then
Tommy comes in with his with his flute
the dragon Zord raises from the water
and they merged again and become the
Megazord and then eventually to make a
dragon Zord and then they call Titanes
which is Bronto Zord
and he gets to the system there they
become the ultra Zord Wow and they take
out Rita and Lord said damn Andrei your
knowledge runs deep um I feel like
they're like I feel like there's a
mother who brought her kid here and it's
just like what did he do what foreign
language is he talking yes human
Wikipedia page Andre Meadows uh Andre uh
you gave us a great layout of the Power
Rangers world just now I think it's time
to introduce the new cast of the Power
Rangers movie
yes let's bring him out let's bring out
Becky G as shree need we got loony Lin
as act the black ring yeah we got
Naomi's Scott is Kimberly the pink
ranger
and we got Decker Montgomery as Jason
the Red Ranger whoo the Power Rangers
Kass everybody give it up for Wow
I'm so sure that's a lady - I'm not my
kid
Wow hey guys doing I'm gonna steal my
baby here okay so welcome to comic-con
you guys yes yes and make a screen
junkies central and also big shout out
he couldn't be here today about big
shout-out to RJ Sylar who is Billy the
Blue Ranger in there yeah he's a cool
game okay yeah welcome you guys thank
you guys for having us we're so excited
to be here so um is if you uh let's
let's talk about screen junkies central
and comic-con have you been in San Diego
for this event before no no we haven't
first time for all those everyone's been
really yeah I've been to San Diego
before it all along Oakley's yeah I've
been across the pond before uh say
what's the pond you've been to America
before tractor ah yes yes I have said
that against rally have you been across
the pond before yeah that's nice it's
that sounded more British yes is it more
British I'm gonna try it she like give
you something else to say sure I'm going
to have tea with the Queen I'm going to
have tea with the Queen that's not bad
yeah that one Thanks
give him a hand give him a hand is
easily my speed most Americans when they
try and do a British accent sound
constipated I mean that's what I do I
always turn to like old cockney one like
I'm going a hot tea with the Queen like
I don't know why I go there I keep
trying but it's very moist Chinese that
we switched it have you guys seen
anything insane so far because the
people watching down here is off the
charts I think we've seen a lot of sorry
didn't yeah your girl redhead ah all
exercise I think we've seen a lot of
positive feedback considering that what
for me in particular I'm an unknown and
there's been a lot of really good online
and now that we're here presence of like
encouragement which is which is great
everyone's been nice yeah a lot of
support for sure a lot of a lot of
positivity I mean it's
it's kind of nervous like nerve-wracking
right we all grew up with this
and yeah it's a beloved franchise
there's a lot of expectations from
ourselves
we feel you guys man but I think I think
there's a magic into this anyways I
think as a whole hugest in general
comic-con has been pretty awesome I mean
the moment I got off the freeway
yesterday and came into the city I was
like whoa this is crazy everybody's
dressed up in costume everybody has
their t-shirts on or like these crazy
like handmade like outfits it's awesome
I think it's really it's really what
dedication is real I feel like
everyone's worried that this whole
events can be like crazy and it's gonna
be tough on us but I feel like if I
can't appreciate this if I can't enjoy
this what can I appreciate this is for
us you know this is a celebration of the
of the passion from the fans this is
strong but I wish this might be a little
secret but I wish I could I might do
this actually dress up a cosplay and go
around the Ranger who would you direct
dress up as not from hi Rangers but know
what you dressed I want whatever I want
each of you to answer night I've gone
one shows the whole thing I've got one
right out that I saw today which is
hilarious I love the outfit it's the
sharknado Elvis yeah sharknado then the
other they were on stilts and there's
sharks coming through them it was insane
that's you I would go for odwin from
Lord of the Rings oh come on now with
their ease like she's so sexy sorry
oh yeah kids like Cate Blanchet no Liv
oh the Tyler Liv Tyler right guys yeah
yeah all right okay good my Ryan all
right
she's such a good holes for her as well
I think it would be um
Khaleesi the mother of dragons
Wow I I want to see that I'm like it
found out though dragon
I might get found out though that might
not be so
not I would just be a powerpuff girl I
don't know I know it's a girl
I mean I've bubbles I always wanted to
be bubbles this one loves everything
hey stripe shirt over there Andre what
would you be um well actually actually
I'm Becky and that's Andre we actually
are cosplaying no actually for the first
time last week I got to actually dress
up as a Ghostbuster with a with an
official proton pack like they made
proton pack wow that was fun that was
really cool if I could only do one
cosplay it would probably be Beyonce
Oh either there is none higher they're
like but it's like mother of dragons
Beyonce all right we make a good team oh
hell yeah
watch out all you single ladies um so uh
you guys tell me what the moment was
like when you found out you were cast as
an iconic shall we go Erica yeah yeah
okay well for me um I freaked out
honestly I remember everybody except for
me knew my managers my mom my dad
everyone and Dean the director calls me
and I was in a fitting so I missed his
call and then I looked and I was like oh
my god this is Dean's number this is the
call this is either that thanks so much
for your time but you're not good enough
and we're going with somebody else or
this is the phone call that's gonna
change my life game changer game changer
I always since growing up I loved the
Power Rangers and I wanted to be the
yellow Power Rangers so it was kind of
weird how it the opportunity came about
and Dean called me and he's like I got a
very serious question for you are you
ready to be the yellow Power Ranger I
just screamed I cried I was very
emotional it being my first film and
being you know something that obviously
influenced me so much growing up it was
it was pretty it was pretty huge Becky
could you imitate that scream for us
right now it would hurt everybody
I think I heard it that night yeah going
throughout the Hollywood Hills someone
just got cast as a power ranger Looney
tell us about your moment okay so when I
found out I was living in China I'm
still living China but I was in China I
called my mom right away is that where
you're originally counted or that's how
I was born
oh yes I'm Chinese hey jump where any
holiday job well Julie Liu the casinos
dad yeah China represents it oh my God
my mom who lives in Canada and and I go
mom I think you know you know that show
I used to watch every single day when I
came home from from school and she goes
I wish I was sure I go you know like the
Power Rangers is your Oh cotton cotton
I'm like no well I just got a role in
Power Rangers she's like I'll just
cartoon I'm like no I think there's some
people acting in it she goes okay I'm
like she goes what role I'm like oh the
the Black Power Ranger and she all black
white black like I like well I know it's
pretty cool mom she's like black always
a bad guy I like no I'm pretty sure he's
a good guy anyways it's cool don't worry
about it and I called my friends and
they're like oh dude awesome yeah your
mom sounds like my mom like shoot my mom
be like wait you're gonna get hurt yeah
be careful your mom's not Jewish like my
mama mama-mama fern and so Naomi oh gosh
so I was just at home on the couch
watching maybe something a bit trashy I
don't know and but keeping up with the
kardashians no no no um there's a show
called Made in Chelsea it's an English
shows it's kind of like a I don't know
anyway you don't need to know is another
great yeah I mean it's not like Jersey
Shore cuz Jersey she was like it's like
rich people like rich young kids but
they're actually rich oh they're not
pretending to be rich anyways was
watching a show what was with one of my
best friends and I got a call from my
manager and it was kind of like this
thing of okay so it
not official but uh and I was like what
so I it was kind of this weird thing of
we didn't know whether it was official
or not for like an hour so I'm just
sitting there like really could be and
then I popped up on Instagram
Naomi Scott is the pink Power Ranger and
I was like I think that's official
seeing as it was like okay official
Instagram so I was like I I think this
is it
so um yeah that's great Wow
yeah I had a really interesting
experience I I was just finishing acting
school or drama school and the very last
night of the very last play of 3rd year
I I was out having mac mces McDonald's
my maid was the end of the year it had a
few beers and and we were late donald's
beers at McDonald's yeah and I got a
void BYO and oh yeah we had we anyway I
got a message saying can you you know
tape for Power Rangers in the morning I
thought okay I'll get up and learn it so
I got up at 7 o'clock I think and I had
five missed calls from my now manager
going they want you to be on a plane
tomorrow and I didn't even tape I was
like oh my god what like what is going
on and they'd seen something else and
said can can you come over so I got on a
plane
traded my business class ticket for two
coach tickets and brought my mom and and
we landed on the Saturday so day later
and met with the director and then
Sunday morning I tested and then Monday
morning they said had the roll so four
days that changed my so easy
Wow like not so II I mean what sensor
which many yeah I was like but it was uh
it's definitely the same as I think all
these guys a life-changing moment of
going I just did the test I'm gonna find
out they've told me tomorrow and
literally standing in the shower with my
head under the water and thinking I'm
gonna get a call in the next ten minutes
and then walking outta mum's crying and
she's like my baby my baby boy you've
yeah my mom is daddy that's a beautiful
story I have one question one follow-up
question
can you I just still need to clarify do
they or don't they serve beer at
McDonald's Australia haha I think we
like to think I do but I may have
brought a few sneaky ones all right to
say McDonald's America needs to catch up
yeah right now what I think interesting
cuz we talk you hear a lot of talk about
which superheroes and like trying to get
different types out there and that's one
thing I've always liked about Power
Rangers has always been a diverse team
and it's just even with this casting you
guys are from all over the world
different placement country yeah so was
that interesting to have you all come
together with dis various backgrounds
than having to work together on this
movie that's better right there like you
said come together right it's all about
it's all about togetherness it's all
about unity yeah it's all about unity
and we uh they did did such a good job
made such a brave decision in casting
diversity right and that's important
because at the end of the day to the
core no matter if you're fan of the
original Japanese series or the or the
TV series or anything that follows after
but to the core there's been so much
diversity throughout the Power Rangers
universe but the cores the Power Rangers
and the core is just togetherness
teamwork and then love and positivity is
and that's a so I think the casting
decision they made here is very brave
because it sticks to the core yeah I
thought cuz that end of the day we're
all just people and we all just want to
work together together for something
better
we're all different ethnicities as
always yeah it's interesting I mean I
I'm I was born in Australia but my mum's
Canadian my dads are Kiwis from New
Zealand and then now you I'm half Indian
whoop-whoop any Indians in the house
yeah we're just me East India where you
where they're just ashamed I think no no
Jackie no one oh wow
I'm representing yeah and obviously
you're Chinese yes very true I mean
what's your get guys yeah yeah um me
being latina is is a huge hey oh no it
was
mean honestly and I think to you know
the unity and everything the
togetherness and all of us being able to
come from different places and find this
common ground we all share the same
passions the same dream and not only
that we're all aware of the
responsibility that we're carrying on
our shoulders and we wear it with pride
because we are very excited to be a part
of this so it's just a huge honor
because that's what I was wanting like
as much as it must be awesome to this
was there any kind of like oh my gosh
this franchise has been around forever
and now I've been to I think I think I
think for me it was definitely a moment
of obviously appreciating that the
franchise has such a already huge fan
following but I think it was me more the
responsibility of stepping into those
shoes of a superhero of somebody that
people look up to somebody that fights
crime looks after the good in the
universe all those kind of things and go
a lot of people look up to you for to
have certain qualities and it might not
be having beer at Macker and 3:00 in the
morning so tell me about the moment when
you first saw the new badass power
ranger costumes because they got serious
upgrades it's like oh these are the new
paths these ain't your mama's Power
Rangers what was alarming process with
the students I don't think anybody
really knows the process that we went
through I mean before we started filming
we were doing like all these crazy cool
3d scans so they can start custom making
them to our bodies and then we tried him
on for the first time it was like a
three-hour process and me and they did
it together we were both starving so you
best believe we were hangry we were like
ty standing there like uncomfortable but
once it was all on once we put our masks
on it was really moving it was like wow
this is real Wow and I mean it's crazy I
think yeah it was it was a surreal
moment how easy is it to move in those
suits good I mean Lutie made it very
easy show olá it gets it gets easier
over time like as your body warms up
like working for you you can trade a bob
relationship with the suit
you have to listen you have to befriend
the suit you have to talk it's a
love-hate relationship behind listen if
it doesn't listen to you beat it inside
no but but our stunt guys though you
should see them like fly around in the
sea yeah and I look at that and I go if
they can do it why can't we do it right
so we step up and yeah there's were made
a bit differently than out yeah there
was your Asians definitely a bit more
room in it to move around yeah but I
mean obviously what's different about
our suits is we they kind of grow on us
they're part of us they're part of our
genetics I'd say and so it's like an a
second armor you know which is kind of
cool and I think what's really cool too
is it's also like like a metaphoric
thing in a sense like I think then it
was actually stepping into a suit but
you'll see in this film it's actually
learning that the suit comes from within
it's finding that inner strength in
yourself and owning it and being
confident in that
and in doing and finding that strength
within other people to and I think
that's really cool and unique about the
suits this time around and one thing I
do want to say sorry man one thing I do
want to say to the fans about the suits
is I mean there's I mean there's a lot
riding on the suits right and I've seen
so much fan work come out like I've seen
incredible fan work yeah I'm out on
other designs pursuits and don't hate on
any of the suits it's all good like it's
the it's the time and the passion you
take into creating these suits right
you're not going to be disappointed by
the new suits by any means but I want to
say some of the other suits out there
they're pretty incredible medals all
aren't working passionate yeah they are
we learned that yeah I definitely did
the whole concept behind the suits is
that the actual morph is organic like
the others were saying it cut it
literally comes from within and and a
big shout-out to whehter who made a
great the suit I actually flew out to
New Zealand went to their workshop got
to meet all the amazing people there and
see all of the incredible Lord of the
Rings and Hellboy and everything out
there and which was incredible for me
because I grew up watching all of these
things and it's done such an incredible
job when somebody goes Power Rangers but
they go organic it's coming from you
know outside of you it's not armor that
you put on and then for them to come up
with this multi-layered you know costume
that is that
you know so many layers semi yeah how
long does the imagination going wild now
with the word organic but also evolved
from that concept it's much more than
that it's like it's it's a philosophy
it's really Zen or the suits are coming
from weight as Power Rangers or religion
joint isn't it fortunate Oh now for some
people it is is there a chance that I
have a suit inside of me let me know you
know what I'm gonna do some
soul-searching tonight and that's why to
follow up how long literally does it
take to put the suit on to nose yeah and
once they were done anyway like the last
the last couple times we had to have
them on I think we broke a record we did
it in an hour which was yeah well cuz
you know we learned he's been out on a
house often the whole sort of process is
that you basically got like multiple
jumps or single how do you what he call
like a cochlea targeting you know you're
tardy jumps and things and they're
they're multiple so every time you put
the next layer on it adds a sort of
different texture and then the final
layer is all this armor coming together
so it's quite it's quite tight and
conversant it is not one thing even
though the materials are so light it is
cumbersome in the sense that because
it's so tight you're sort of restricted
in your movement um but yeah we'd have
like four or five costume ladies so
helpful so but we kind of got it out
always baby you learn these fun little
shortcuts like you only put on an arm or
you don't put on the suit pants feel
like news anchors I never got that yeah
just the year boxer shorts yeah and then
I remember asking the question when we
first put on the suit is like so how do
we use the restroom oh because we have
some layers but yeah it was like I mean
on ways Oh bless our stunt doubles like
there was one time Kimmy I'm sorry for
that moment that we had I mean seriously
it was difficult there there's I mean no
actually I don't want to spoil yeah
we won't go there it was difficult I'll
be better is there any truth to the
rumor that part of the suit was a Power
Rangers diaper hmm
kidding I was about to say
potentially but folks I was thinking
underoos yeah it was like it was called
the blue suit we'd like a poop chute and
a little you know like dungarees I think
that's me for the brown bear like yeah
yeah well yeah I just I just know that
when that moment comes in the movie went
like you first morph into those suits I
know the audience of myself is maybe
like I just seen that movie that's right
yeah wait hey you guys we the first
moment you see the movie uh you know you
see the suit on whatever you guys should
film self your own reactions then post
online but no wait are you encouraging
the movie theaters selfies okay I will
say don't go to the movie do it anyway
see Power Rangers do not take a selfie
after the movie yeah there will be
people in prison and then we like Ludi
Linda told me to do those it's cool man
I'm from China
excuses I'm speaking with lu d that
comment just broke the internet so uh
you mentioned the your stunt doubles and
we know there is intense physical action
lighting alien it was crazy
actually we trained all of us kind of
got to train a little bit before we even
got there for filming I mean you and you
will you have the most experience but
far I mean I mean everybody there's not
an ounce of fat on the best body come on
don't know but it was cool we got to
train ourselves and I also shout-out to
her stunt doubles who really went out of
their way to help us figure out our
fighting styles for our characters are
really making them unique and and we did
a lot of our own stunts yeah we were
great we worked on um but it was it was
hard because you know I'm from Inglewood
I don't know I kind of had an idea I had
a fight before hand and go load up to
but the concept of fighting for camera
is very different this person is not
your opponent that your partner so their
safety comes first so learning camera
blocking and stacking and safety boxes
and fully going for a punch but knowing
in your body that you are not going to
hit this person it can't get higher
though because the first time that I
ever did choreography on camera
apparently they say it's very normal you
get nervous and the nervous enok all
your distances just you just forget and
I just I mean poor will who was playing
a party by the way guys just boom and
bled he bled yes I mean we made his lip
bleed Wow training I didn't know well
for the nicest guys my knuckles were
bleeding and it never happened again
these two had a little bit of an
altercation as well they had their own
moment that was brother yes let's just
say he's got a powerful a backhand when
it clocks it took me straight out clean
ice we go after we even yeah we I got
him back unintentionally but I think
it's great because from my first day we
you know had that this huge crazy stunt
scene which you'll find out it's at the
very beginning of the filming almost
shot chronologically in a way in a weird
way it was quite ordered anyway so from
the day that I was there my stunt double
Frank who's the most incredible guy he
is Assassin's Creed like how cool is
that he does all the motion cap for that
for that game and just the nicest guy
and like that's the kind of support when
you go and set and you're like
regardless of where you're at you love
that this guy is like any so nice and
quiet and from helping to put it on our
harnesses
yeah I'm sure all of our wires were
clear to making sure that if we had to
go somewhere of dangerous Heights they
were right there bar sides kind of
guiding us through everything so yeah we
felt very safe absolutely and what I
said before about this film like the
word together really it's not just us
and so us our stunt guys and then the
entire crew crew that crafted it like
it's Zac it's not now that's the crap
robson that guy who we discussed what
his fighting style should be what it
could be what's and our director as well
and hopefully in the future when the
movie comes out it'll be us together as
fans and audiences and people that's how
we complete the Power Rangers it's it's
it should be a religion it should spread
or a cult so every time every time some
announcement like when you guys got
announced one by one I would get like
messages and whatever but one morning my
Twitter just went nope nope nope crazy
because they announced Elizabeth Banks
yeah yeah maybe as Rita Repulsa
so when you guys found out about that
well how did you guys feel when you
heard that announcement ah um my mom was
like is she the one from Hunger Games
and I was like yeah I'm pretty sure she
is and like it's that whole thing of
like not just that she's been in Hunger
Games but you get on set and you're
working with somebody who's a seasoned
successful actress actor actress what
you yeah it's like suddenly you're
functioning in this realm where this
person makes you think like gives you
options gives you so much to work with
that you actually have to work harder
you have to bring your game up because
yeah there I remember on the on the
first day that I met her I probably
can't say it's probably gonna give a
spoiler but um but let's just say she
just forced me in such a great way to be
like yeah it makes him like really big
creative decisions here and that and
that actually that's the like it's a
whole nother learning steps thing she's
such a character actress as well like
she's able to take something on paper
and really bring it to life and in this
kind of this mix of the insanity but
she's funny but she's beautiful cieariy
but she's kind of beautiful she's like
everything and she's fearless so she
went in to add on to what nee was saying
about her I think what I loved the most
about working with her she was involved
in every aspect of her character as far
as development wise making adjustments
to the script and saying you know I feel
like as her character you know maybe it
would go a little bit more this way or
she would say something like this or
just even just saying it
we're filming you know and taking those
risk and then as cosmetic wise you know
when it came to the prosthetics and the
costumes just knowing where her
character was at every phase in the
movie was it was really inspiring to see
yeah she's fantastic she does drama she
does comedy she's loved her early songs
I think and then we saw that picture in
Entertainment Weekly where she's like
got you or she's like oh I wouldn't say
I actually had bruises because it was so
intense like it was cool to - we did our
blocking and such as her and I and Dean
and it was cool cuz we were like in
sweats no makeup hair in a trunk or like
not even carrying oh sorry in a bun I
got super lucky no you're good like a
jungle um and it was just super chill no
pressure and then you know come today of
filming our scenes and I'm like oh my
god this is real and she comes in in
full costume and it just it was like
throw me into the wall girl like let's
make this real and so the day after I'm
like oh maybe she shouldn't have done
that this hard like I'm hurting right
now and obviously other big casting news
Bryan Cranston Yeah right
tell us what is what it was like did you
have any scenes with uh or working with
him what it was like well huge cuz even
before Bryan Cranston was announced as
cast we were like we're doing table
reads and stuff we're wondering like
what's Warren's gonna be like yeah I
think we had so many Zordon you know we
had like every Foreman's or Donkin room
like imagine like Darth Vader's or Don
Harry Potter resort we'd make our own
voices would sit around the table you
know either the director would read or
read read and then another actor came in
a great voice actor for a period and and
played his spoke his lines so we're so
you know developing this relationship
with this patriarchal character of being
like this is the guy who guides us
through this journey yeah this is the
solid this is the foundation under the
ranges like this is the guy who's goes
you've got this responsibility you've
got to step up yeah and then for Brian
to step in that role especially like I
watch malcolm in the middle' shout out
to Breaking Bad literally right
and now finding the middle and I'm like
he's my dad like mouthing to me I was
like this is great well isn't it just
right though Bryan Cranston like it just
feels right action oh yeah he has so
much gravity to the role and you guys
you've got me so excited for this movie
just talking to you and hearing you just
the commitment and dedication and the
belief you have in the movie isn't that
awesome to hear you guys I want to thank
you for coming out and joining us today
decorate Montgomery Naomi Scott luteal
in Becky G thank you for coming out
spending time with us thank you thank
you thank you thank you everybody a kiss
love you guys yeah we're gonna take a
picture we're gonna take some pictures
nice
thanks again to sponsor t-mobile with
double the LTE coverage hit your screen
junkies fix and more places to watch our
previous show click to the left and to
view everything else from screen junkie
central click to the right